my mom sent me some pictures that I drew
as a child and one of them looks oh this
is a self-portrait I did when I was
young and I thought applying my recent
my recent you know Photoshop skills
I'm going to make myself look like I did
there for [ __ ] sake
why stop I have this pre-prepared image
that we're going to use as shaping
material it's a good idea over an
entertaining video prop probably not
probably not oh my god okay so sexy
first off we need the shape of the head
to be correct
[Music]
sometimes God allows what hate to
accomplish what you love I love my
facial expression as well if it fits
perfectly I predicted the hair color
pretty well except mine looks more like
wearing a waffle or something
although the note is spot-on
poor nose curse is a giant nose it's not
bare all right let's move the eyes I
guess I guess I don't have eyebrows
technically yeah that that doesn't look
terrifying at all yeah this is beautiful
we're getting we're getting there we're
getting there
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm getting scared I am getting what's
up looking okay and moving on to the
nose shouldn't be much a change meant
required honestly I think I captured
this horrific thing pretty well there
what's the call like that the speed
meter doesn't work I don't know how fast
I'm going the blinkers doesn't work
it made me well nauseous driving because
I feel so weird
no it's definitely you okay you know I
predicted it pretty well I think a you
know what an art in Jesus Christ I want
to die I want to die a horrible death I
also had this amazing photograph I mean
it looks like a photograph
o me when I am 64 years old Wow her
kicks well I had a slightly
disproportionate Nick I would say that's
fine
completely fine why why am I doing this
I wonder if the younger version of
myself would be impressed or just a be
diggin I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
hahahaha oh my god yeah I really
predicted the future well didn't I
for some reason I am [ __ ] red as [ __ ]
yeah we need to adjust that that that
seems pretty accurate I would say I did
not have any hair however on the on the
top so let's let's get rid of that
[Music]
clearly you know in the future I'm a lot
happier than I am on this Vagan picture
so let's try and adjust that oh my god
for some reason my eyes are [ __ ]
green greenish I'm slowly starting to
become the son of Satan
okay let's do the glasses
[Music]
you
and there's the result that's actually
kind of funny I'm sure you've seen this
by now because it is probably going to
be out later but this came out today
it's [ __ ] hilarious
you can basically draw any stick figure
and this computer will make it into a
cat I'm not joking
I'll show you okay are you ready are you
ready Hey hahahaha what the [ __ ]
happened here god damn it
which also of course means you can have
cat penises science have done a great
deed today it does lead us honestly not
look bad yes it's a spider cat of course
of course it's a spider cat what else
could it be
what about boob cat oh no Felix please
do not turn me into that demon I don't
want you please don't do it
No No ah that's good yeah what if cat
were human a question that should never
have been answered
no one's you've ever have known what it
man
talking now yeah it looks pretty good
hahahaha yes yes
hell yeah all right what about [ __ ]
keemstar I don't know I can't look at
this I can't I don't want it this is why
you should never you should never play
with science